so jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt das ist ein Antrag
der afd-fraktion hier auf Einsetzung
einer on-cat-kommission mit dem Titel
Sicherstellung der Energieversorgung für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
afd-fraktion möchte also eine solche
orcat-kommission
einberufen nach
§ 56 der Geschäftsordnung des
Bundestages ich kann eine
oncat-kommission
eingerichtet werden auf Antrag eines
Viertels der Abgeordneten beispielsweise
die Fraktion wir hören zum Auftakt der
Debatte reiner Kraft für die
afd-fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen es ist der mittlerweile eine
Binsenweisheit dass Deutschland aufgrund
einer falschen Energiepolitik in
existenzielle Schwierigkeiten geraten
ist und er hilft der Verweis auf den
russischen Angriffskrieg gar nichts denn
bereits im Frühjahr 2019 also drei Jahre
drei Jahre vor dem russischen Einmarsch
wurde die deutsche Energiepolitik vom
Wall Street Journal ganz treffend als
dümmste Energiepolitik der Welt
bezeichnet
landaufland ab warten sie das Land gegen
die Gefahren eines unvorhergesehenen
Stromausfalls oder auch vieler geplanter
stundenweise Stromabschaltungen und das
obwohl Deutschland doch nach außerhalb
des zuständigen Ministers der heute
keine Zeit hat kein Stromproblem habe
gleichzeitig werden seit 2020
Kraftwerkskapazitäten von 8 GB bei
can-energie und runden 10 GB bei
Kohleverstromung abgebaut das zumindest
Letzteres keine so gute Idee war hat die
Regierung ja auch mit der Einbringung
des ersatzkraftwerk
bereithaltungsgesetzes hinreichend
bewiesen
parallel verfügt Deutschland nun über
zwei Gesetze die zum einen das Verbot
des Betriebes eines Kohlekraftwerkes
fordern und mit einem zweiten Gesetz den
Betrieb genau diese kohlenkraftwerke ist
wieder erlaubt welche energiepolitischer
Irrsinn auch das gleiche wird uns bei
der Kernkraft erwarten ein Gesetz wird
kommen müssen dass ein Betrieb erlaubt
obwohl doch eigentlich vom Gesetzes
wegen der Betrieb verboten ist ähnlich
sieht es aus beim Erdgas Methan aus
sogenannten unkonventionellen
Gewinnungsmethoden umgangssprachlich als
Fracking bezeichnet zu gewinnen ist in
Deutschland verboten gleichzeitig soll
aber der Import von dem Ausland
gewonnenen fracking-gas massiv erhöht
werden und dazu wurde extra ein Gesetz
geschaffen das sogenannte lng-
diese Beispiele zeigen uns ganz klar die
deutsche Energiepolitik hat sich
hoffnungslos verrannt und wird nur noch
durch behelfsmäßige Flickschusterei am
Leben gehalten
die Kosten für diesen dahinsichenden
Patienten genannt Energiepolitik die
sind dabei so groß dass sie von einer
stark zunehmenden Zahl von privaten und
auch unternehmerischen Abnehmern nicht
länger geschultert werden können und die
Folgen sind Abwanderung der
wertschöpfenden Industrie und die
Verarmung des Volkes
was diese und auch die vorhergehenden
Regierung offensichtlich nicht
verstanden haben Energie ist die Basis
unseres Wohlstandes sie ist für
Wirtschaft und Volk so wichtig wie für
uns der Sauerstoff und daher hat sich
ständig in ausreichenden Mengen zur
Verfügung zu stehen und darfst auch die
Kosten die Bezieher nicht unnötig
belasten die Energiepolitik der
vergangenen 20 Jahre hat aber das
Gegenteil dessen gemacht neue Formen der
Energieerzeugung wurden mit Milliarden
an Steuergeldern etabliert obwohl
keinerlei Beleg für die technische
Machbarkeit dieses Unterfangens
existiert hat
bevor eine Ersetzung der erprobten
energieerzeugungsmethoden sowohl in
technische Hinsicht also eine Fragen der
Verlässlichkeit als auch in den Fragen
der Regionalität erzogen hätte
stattfinden dürfen hätte dieses Konzept
der sogenannten Erneuerbaren in kleine
Maßstab getestet werden müssen um die
Machbarkeit und die reellen Kosten zu
ermitteln in solch einem Labor hätte man
dann ganz schnell gemerkt dass der Preis
weit über eine Kugel Eis liegt und dass
die Zuverlässigkeit der
Energieversorgung mangelhaft ist aber
das wurde nicht gemacht
berufsfremde hier ruft gerade eine rein
berufsrente überbezahlte Menschen ohne
vorzeigbare Mieter zerschlugen in
Maschinen stürmen den Eifer all die
Techniken und Fundamente der
energetischen Basis dieses Landes
letzte Woche packen wir im Bundestag
Besuch von ukrainischen Kollegen aus der
wir hoffen nach Rada dem ukrainischen
Parlament der Vorsitzende des
gasausschusses andré schubanin hat uns
in bewegenden Worten geschildert wie
derzeit die Energieinfrastruktur der
Ukraine durch russische Angriffe gezielt
zerstört wird das Ziel Russland ist
offensichtlich die Ukraine soll doch
Zerstörung der Möglichkeiten Energie zu
erzeugen zu verteilen oder auch zu
verkaufen in die Knie gezwungen werden
hier in Deutschland braucht es dazu
weder Raketen noch Bomben noch iranische
kamikazedonen denn die Grundlagen der
Energieversorgung werden von der
Regierung selbst zertrümmert seit 2011
sind zum Beispiel 14 moderne
kernkraftwerksblöcke stillgelegt worden
mit einer Nennleistung von 20 Gigawatt
Kraftwerke nach denen nicht nur die
Ukraine die Finger abschlecken würde und
sie haben sie abgeschaltet um das zu
verdeutlichen ein Beispiel hätten wir
noch 17 Kernkraftwerke dann kann man
deren erzeugte Energie auf ungefähr 180
Tera Stunden hochrechnen die gesamte
Erzeugung von Strom aus Kohle und Gase
im vergangenen Jahr 2021 waren 240
Terawattstunden und das heißt zwei
Drittel der fossilen Energieerzeugung
hätten vergangenes Jahr durch keine
Energie ersetzt werden können so viel zu
ihren angeblichen
klimaeinsparungsmaßnahmen und das
gleiche gilt auch für dieses Jahr 2022
in den Regierung jetzt um nach Gas und
Kohle bettelt und hätten wir keinen
Energie müssen wir das Dorf lützerat
nicht wegbaggern
die von der Regierung angepriesenen
Energieträger Wind und Sonne haben 2021
nur ca 150 Terabyte Stunden geliefert
letztes Jahr und das heißt nach über 20
Jahren der Dauer Subventionierung
schaffen es diese zufallsregierung
zufallsenergie nicht auch nur die
Leistung der Kernkraftwerke zu
substituieren und vom Ersatz von Kohle
und Gas ist ja noch gar nicht die Rede
das sind die harten Fakten in ihrem
Energiewende Märchen
und ich stelle mir die Frage wo das
hinführen soll ganz einfach das Ziel ist
es dass Deutschland wieder ein
Energieversorgung bekommt die den
Vorgaben der Gender 2030 entspricht
bezahlbar zuverlässig nachhaltig und
modern und das wird die Aufgabe dieser
Kommission sein
und weil hier die ganze Zeit die
Eingriffe kommen zu den sogenannten
Erneuerbaren nein niemand stellt die
Fähigkeit von Windindustrieanlagen und
Photovoltaik in Frage Strom produzieren
zu können und es wäre eine hervorragende
gute Sache wenn die Menge an Erzeugung
eben auch dem entsprechenden Verbrauch
passen würde nur dass es ihm leider so
gut wie niemals der Fall und daher
müssen ständig teure Ersatzmaßnahmen
greifen um diese ganzen Defizite zu
überbrücken
zukünftig soll dann Energie die
produziert wird in eine speicherbare
Form überführt werden um dann in Zeiten
der ständigen unterproduktion aktiviert
zu werden und zu diesem Zweck ist es
dann nötig gewaltige zusätzliche Mengen
eine Energie zu erzeugen um die dabei
auftreten Verluste zu kompensieren das
ist jetzt eine megalomanische Idee
derzeit denn nicht nur soll die jetzige
Stromversorgung eins zu eins ersetzt
werden sondern darüber hinaus sollen
riesige Mengen an Energie erzeugt werden
mit dem einzigen Zweck die gigantischen
wandlungsverlusten zu kompensieren
reinen Wasserstoff raus den Wasserstoff
rein die Batterie raus überträgt also
Energie zu erzeugen mit dem einzigen
Zweck sie wieder zu verschwenden
diese Evaluation betraf jetzt nur den
Stromsektor aber sie wird sich noch
mehrere Größenordnung erhöhen wenn sie
wie geplant den gesamten Primärsektor
Energiesektor erfassen soll
wir stellen fest
denn die Energiesektor in Deutschland
ist stark reformbedürftig die Regierung
doktort mittlerweile im Monatstakt mit
neuen Gesetzen an den Symptomen herum
und es ist der deswegen an der Zeit dass
die Legislative zurückgeht zurück zur
Wurzel um die Energiepolitik die Basis
des Wohlstandes dieses Landes wieder in
die richtige Spur in die richtigen Bahn
zu lenken
[Applaus]
die hier diesen Antrag gestellt hat eine
okette-kommission einzurichten wir
öffnen jetzt die erste Erwiderung von
Markus 5er für die SPD
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren Herr Dr
Kraft sie wollen eine onkette-kommission
einsetzen und reden am Thema vorbei
ihnen geht es doch gar nicht um die
Kommission ihnen geht es nur darum
Atomkraft wieder zu reaktivieren obwohl
die so teuer ist was ist denn mit dem
Müll wer soll das denn bezahlen
wofür ist eine und cat-kommission da
lassen sie mich aus dem Handwörterbuch
politisches System der Bundeszentrale
für politische Bildung zitieren denn
politische Bildung das tut uns hier
allen gut manchen ganz besonders
nach nach Paragraph 56 seiner
Geschäftsordnung kann der Deutsche
Bundestag eine onkett-kommission zur
Vorbereitung von Entscheidungen über
umfangreiche und bedeutsame sachkomplexe
einrichten
umfangreiche um bedeutsame sachkomplexe
das heißt dass man sie nicht ausreichend
in einzelnen
Gesetzgebungsverfahren abbilden kann
weil sie verschiedene Themen und
Dimensionen Vereinen zum Beispiel
Internet und digitale Gesellschaft
künstliche Intelligenz berufliche
Bildung und digitale Arbeitswelt alles
Titel vergangener on cat-kommissionen
weil es um solche komplexen großen
Themen geht heißt es im Handwörterbuch
weiter die Arbeitsergebnisse der
onkette-kommission haben in der Regel
mittel bis langfristige Wirkung indem
sie das Problem be sein für komplizierte
Sachverhalte schärfen jetzt beantragen
Sie eine concat-kommission für die
Sicherstellung der Energieversorgung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und für
dieses Thema ist eine on-cat-kommission
gänzlich ungeeignet
erstens brauchen wir die Sicherstellung
der Energieversorgung jetzt und nicht
erst Mittel- und langfristig zweitens
benötigen wir nicht noch ein weiteres
parlamentarisches Gremium zu Bearbeitung
eines Problems im Hier und Jetzt es gibt
wunderbare Ausschüsse in diesem Haus
denen sie auch angehören in diesen
ausschütze
Ausschüssen werden in jeder
Sitzungswoche genau die Themen
diskutiert die sie genannt haben und das
beispielsweise Fragen die abstrus sind
nicht auf der Tagesordnung landen lässt
sich nicht dadurch lösen dass die
Tagesordnung einfach einen anderen
Briefkopf bekommt
drittens sind und cat-kommission für
komplizierte Sachverhalte gedacht die
über dem gesetzgeberischen Verfahren
schweben die Energiewende unser
Energiesystem die Energieversorgung das
sind keine philosophischen Fragen
sondern ganz konkrete Materie
viertens würde eine und cat-kommission
auch nicht das tun was sie sich davon
wünschen
ich zitiere wieder das Handwörterbuch
dass der Bundestag aus den Empfehlungen
einer on-cat-kommission konkrete
Gesetzgebungsverfahren entwickelt ist
eher die Ausnahme aus einer und
cat-kommission entwickelt sich in der
Regel ein
Problembewusstsein ein geschärftes
Verständnis dass dann in die Politik der
verschiedenen Ressorts einfließt was sie
sich aber wünschen ist ein Rollback in
der Energiepolitik sie wollen mit
suggestiven Fragen die Ergebnisse der
Kommission vorwegnehmen sie sprechen zum
Beispiel von sogenannten regenerativen
Energien oder von den Anführungszeichen
grünem Wasserstoff sie suggerieren
Energie offen Ergebnisoffenheit
schneiden aber die Fragen auf die
Ergebnisse zu zum Beispiel die
Auswirkungen der Energiewende auf Brown
und Blackout Gefahr
verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch die
Energiewende kostet Geld sicherlich die
Energiewende ist auch nicht für jeden
leicht zu stemmen und die Energiewende
wird aber in jedem ehrlichen und Fähren
nicht verzerrten Kosten Nutzen Vergleich
gewinnen denn die Alternativen sind ganz
sicher viel schlechter für unsere
Versorgungssicherheit Bezahlbarkeit für
das Klima und auch für das
gesellschaftliche Klima
ich schaue die Analysen und Abwägungen
ganz und gar nicht nur ist eine
orchet-kommission nicht der richtige
Platz dafür denn wenn ich deren Kosten
und Nutzen Abwege komme ich zu dem
Schluss das lohnt sich nicht denn das
Forum für diese Auseinandersetzung das
gibt's bereits das sind die Ausschüsse
Klimaschutz und Energie Wirtschaft und
auch Arbeit und Soziales und nicht nur
in den Ausschüssen ich habe ihnen
gestern hier
an dieser Stelle erklärt was wir alles
machen um die Energiesicherheit zu
gewährleisten Ausweitung von Biogas
streckbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
Kohlekraftwerke
lng-terminals vieles mehr wir stellen
die Energieversorgung Sicherheit sicher
stellen sie sich der Debatte bringen sie
überzeugende Argumente ein ein weiteres
Forum in Form einer und cat-kommission
braucht es nicht deswegen werden wir
Ihren Antrag ablehnen danke
besagt Markus hümpfer hier für die
SPD-Fraktion ja die letzte
oncat-kommission die der Bundestag
eingesetzt hat das war übrigens im
Sommer 2022 zu den Lehrern aus dem
Afghanistan Einsatz dieser
onkel-kommission die arbeitet der Zeit
nächste in der Aussprache hier Fabian
gramling für die Union sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wie lange tagt eigentlich eine
okette-kommission im Deutschen Bundestag
im Schnitt sind es zwei Jahre manchmal
auch drei Jahre und ich sage Ihnen ganz
offen als Mitglied im Klima und
energieausschuss für das fühle ich mich
fühlt sich für mich die Zeitspanne
zwischen den vollmundigen Ankündigungen
der Regierung und der vermeintlichen
Umsetzung schon heute wie eine halbe
Ewigkeit an aber der hier vorliegende
Vorschlag ganz nach dem Motto wenn du
nicht mehr weiter weißt bilde einen
Arbeitskreis geht an der Realität
vollkommen vorbei
denn der Blick auf die kommenden Monate
und Jahres klar wir müssen die
Energieinfrastruktur ausbauen
Stromtrassen die südlink
leistungsfähiges wasserstoffnetz und den
Ausbau Beschleunigen im Zweifel per
Gesetz wir müssen erneuerbare Energien
weiter ausbauen je nach Potenzial dort
wo es sich lohnt und wo es sich rentiert
wir müssen die Speicherkapazitäten
ausbauen wie in Baden-Württemberg dort
entsteht der größte Batteriespeicher der
Welt nur so kann nämlich die
Energiewende wirklich gelingen wir
müssen die Rohstoffversorgung
sicherstellen durch mehr Forschung für
substitute mit mehr Kreislaufwirtschaft
und der Rohstoffgewinnung im Inland wie
beispielsweise Gas und auch
mittelfristig Lithium und wir müssen die
Energieversorgung endlich europäisch
denken liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine oket-kommission hilft uns aktuell
nicht weiter was zu tun ist das liegt
auf der Hand jetzt liegt es erstmal an
der Regierung aber
aber die Performance der Regierung
allein in dieser Woche hat mal wieder
gezeigt nicht die letzten 16 Jahre sind
in diesem Land das Problem zu den
letzten 16 Wochen sind in diesem Land
das Problem liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und liebe liebe Kollegen der Ampel sie
verweisen gerne auf Experten sie
verweisen gerne auf die Wissenschaft
hören Sie doch bitte auf die Leiterin
ihrer Expertenkommission auf ihre
Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm ihre
Expertin sagt Trennelemente beschaffen
Kernkraft über den April 23 hinaus am
Netz lassen und damit ganz nebenbei den
Strompreis und 13 bis 16 Prozent senken
das sagt ihre Expertin hören Sie endlich
auf sie müssen und es sind
es sind für mich und für viele Menschen
in diesem Land absolut ist es nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar wenn sie in Zeiten von
explodierenden Energiepreisen in Zeiten
von Unsicherheit und der Sorge vor einem
Blackout diesen Vorschlag ihrer Expertin
leichtsinnig beiseiteschieben und uns
dafür beschimpfen
der Kanzler der spricht zwar gerne vom
you will never walk alone
am Ende hat er mit seiner
richtlinienentscheidung selbst einen
Alleingang gemacht und seien auf der
sommerpressekonferenz seinen auf der
Pressekonferenz selbst formulierten
Anspruch es sei seine Aufgabe dass sich
die Regierung zusammensetzt und Probleme
gemeinsam löst diesem Anspruch ist der
Kanzel diese Woche nicht mehr gerecht
geworden die Schlussfolgerung von Franz
Müntefering ist hier im Hohen Haus
glaube ich hinlänglich bekannt die
Grünen und Teile der SPD ist schon 40
sehen sich um den Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie Ende des Jahres gebracht für
den sie schon die Renaissance der CO2
Emittenten Kohlekraft akzeptiert haben
Klimaschutz scheint hier an der Stelle
zweite oder sogar nur an der dritten
Geige zu spielen und die FDP jubelt
vorfrüht
versucht krampfhaft einen Punktsieg zu
erzielen und realisiert spät das Scholz
im April 23 alle Kernkraftwerke
abschalten möchte es lohnt sich immer
einen Text bis zum Ende zu lesen bevor
man twittert liebe FDP und der
eigentliche Verlierer in diesem Land der
eigentliche Verlierer bei dieser Debatte
sind aber eigentlich die Menschen in
einer Zeit in der jede Kilowattstunde
zählt in der Unternehmen und
Privathaushalte Energie sparen sollen
und unter hohen Energiepreisen leiden
die letzten Tage haben aber gezeigt von
der ursprünglich gefeierten
fortschrittskoalition ist nach einem
Jahr wenig übrig geblieben aber was mich
nach der Anweisung des Kanzlers am
meisten gewundert hat das war die
Reaktion des Wirtschaftsministers er
meinte den Tagesthemen er kann damit
leben lieber Minister Habeck
es geht hier nicht darum dass sie damit
leben können ihr Taktieren ihre Angst
vor der niedersachsenwahl auf ihre Angst
vor dem grünen Parteitag hat unserem
Land geschadet als Wirtschaftsminister
eine der größten Volkswirtschaften
müssen sie endlich konsequent handeln
statt auf einen warmen Winter zu hoffen
es geht nicht darum wie sie sich fühlen
es geht um Planungssicherheit es geht um
Versorgungssicherheit es geht um
Wohlstand und am Ende des Tages geht es
auch um das Vertrauen in die Politik in
unserem Land meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
und liebe ampelfraktion liebe
ampelregierung wir von der
Unionsfraktion Strecken Ihnen auch nach
wie vor die Hand aus um die
Herausforderung in diesem Land
anzupacken das haben wir konstruktiv das
haben wir konstruktiv in den letzten
Monaten im Ausschuss bewiesen haben auch
Fristen verzichtet wenn ein Gesetz in
die richtige Richtung gegangen ist haben
wir diesem Gesetz auch zugestimmt aber
sie haben die Mehrheit in diesem
Parlament und das respektieren wir und
Sie können ist ja auch ihr gutes Recht
mit ihrer Mehrheit Dinge umzusetzen und
zu beschließen wir sind dann aber nicht
schuld wenn sie nichts aufs Gleis
bekommen deshalb brauchen sie auch nicht
ständig hier im Deutschen Bundestag sich
echauffieren wenn wir ihre Fehler hier
offen ansprechen vielen Dank
Fabian gramling war das für die
CDU-Fraktion der hat sich weniger mit
dem Antrag hier der AFD
auseinandergesetzt der hier diese
Debatte zugrunde lag sondern noch mal
mit der Entscheidung der Ampel die
Atomkraftwerke laut der
richtlinienkomtenz von Kanzler Olaf
Scholz bis Mitte 2023 weiterlaufen zu
lassen jetzt hören wir Ingrid Nestle für
die Grünen Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
gramling ist es tatsächlich schwer
nachvollziehbar wenn sie von der cdu/csu
Tag für Tag wieder über die ein Prozent
Endenergie aus Atomstrom sprechen
während dieses Land verwirklichen
Herausforderung steht und wirkliche
Lösungen braucht
aber
aber eigentlich geht es ja hier um einen
Antrag der AFD um die über den
allerdings die Art die selbst nicht
gesprochen hat und der auch in ihrer
eigenen Fraktion anscheinend nicht
wirklich auf Interesse stößt weil gerade
mal sechs Anwesenden die glaube ich auch
nicht alle wirklich zuhören schauen wir
trotzdem rein was haben sie da gefordert
sie wollen von der AFD dass eine über
Jahre arbeitende Kommission Fragen
untersucht die längst bearbeitet und
intensiv diskutiert sind
nur mal beispielhaft die
fraunhofer-studie zur Klimaneutralität
2045 Prognos die neutralisierten
Versorgungssicherheit die oberstudie zu
Wind und Gesundheit zahllose Sitzungen
im Ausschuss für Energie
sie haben das alles nicht mitbekommen
wir brauchen keine ewige
Wiederholungsschleife wir wissen längst
wie die Energiewende funktionieren kann
was wir jetzt brauchen ist die Umsetzung
wir brauchen
den Auswahl schnell
eigentlich eigentlich hätten wir den
Ausbau schon im letzten Jahrzehnt viel
entschiedener gebraucht und dann hätten
wir die heutigen Probleme gar nicht in
dieser Form
ja die Kollegen von der AFD es ist schon
faszinierend wie sie seit über einer
Legislatur in diesem Parlament sitzen
und nicht mitbekommen haben wollen wie
intensiv diese Fragen aus ihrem Antrag
schon diskutiert worden sind wie viele
studienuntersuchungen und Fakten benannt
und verschickt worden sind
ernsthafte Diskussion prallen an ihnen
ab als hätten sie einen Regenmantel an
dem nicht wasserabpert sondern Fakten
ah ja sie regen sich wieder auf das habe
ich mir gedacht und deswegen habe ich
ihn ein ganz konkretes Beispiel
mitgebracht erst letzte Woche genau hier
habe ich darauf hingewiesen und Sie
können das Nachlesen im Protokoll habe
ich darauf hingewiesen dass ich unsere
einsparappelle eben gerade nicht an die
Leute richten die kein Geld mehr haben
um das zu bezahlen sondern an die
gesamte Gesellschaft und in erster Linie
an die reichen die am meisten Energie
verbrauchen und sparen können klar und
deutlich dann kam so ungefähr eine
Viertelstunde später ihr Kollege Herr
Bernhard und hat mich persönlich
angesprochen und hat behauptet ich hätte
sinngemäß gesagt ja wenn die Energie
Menschen sich die Energie nicht mehr
leisten könnten dann wäre meine
Empfehlung gewesen in Zukunft halt
weniger zu verbrauchen das ist das
komplette Gegenteil dessen was ich
gesagt habe und das kann jeder der die
deutsche Sprache versteht eindeutig
erkennen
Thema gesprochen sie haben gerade
ziemlich protestiert als ich behaupt
habe dass die Fakten und die ernsthaften
Diskussion an ihn irgendwie einfach
abprallen dass sie die onkett-kommission
nur deshalb fordern weil sie gar nicht
gemerkt haben dass all diese Fragen
längst besprochen sind
und tatsächlich wenn sie on
cat-kommissionen so mögen
wenn sie um cat-kommissionen so schätzen
wie kommt es eigentlich dass sie die
Ergebnisse der vergangenen und
cat-kommission noch nicht mal zur
Kenntnis genommen haben schon 1994
kamen-kommission zum Schutz der
Atmosphäre zu dem Schluss eine der
wichtigsten Aufgaben der Energie- und
Umweltpolitik ist die Förderung der
erneuerbaren Energien
ihr Antrag ihr Antrag zeigt klar die AFD
steht gegen die erneuerbaren Energien
denn sie wollen mit Fragen der liebe
Zuschauer wir gehen ganz schnell nach
Brüssel wo Olaf Scholz vor die Presse
tritt zu Beginn des Ministertreffens
schönen guten Tag es ist sehr gut dass
wir jetzt zusammenkommen in einer ganz
besonderen Situation es geht erneut
darum dass wir unsere solidarisch
Unterstützung für die Ukraine
miteinander koordinieren und den guten
Weg der Gemeinsamkeit fortsetzen den wir
begonnen haben gleichzeitig geht es
darum wie wir die
Energieversorgungssicherheit für Europa
sicherstellen können und sicherstellen
können dass die Preise bezahlbar werden
denn das ist klar die Preise für Gas für
Öl für Kohle müssen sinken die
Strompreise müssen sinken und das ist
auch etwas das eine gemeinsame
Anstrengung von uns allen in Europa
erfordert ich bin sehr froh darüber dass
die Europäische Kommission eine ganze
Reihe von guten Denkansätzen und
Vorschlägen vorgelegt hat mit denen wir
uns hier weiter befassen werden und auch
sicherlich nicht nur heute sondern auch
bei einer späteren Gelegenheit das noch
dann zu vertiefen haben werden ganz
wichtig ist dass wir die Möglichkeit
nutzen die jetzt erkennbar sind zum
Beispiel dass Unternehmen die
privatwirtschaftlich Gas in der Welt
Einkaufen diese Aktivitäten auch
miteinander koordiniert vornehmen können
da sind heute
wettbewerbsrechtliche Hindernisse die
beiseite geräumt werden und das ist ein
wichtiger Beitrag zur Koordinierung ist
es auch wichtig dass wir unsere
Strategien koordinieren wie die Speicher
gefüllt werden im nächsten Jahr das ist
wichtig damit die Preise nicht steigen
aber die Speicher gleichwohl voll sind
voll haben wir sie dieses Jahr gekriegt
aber die Koordinierung wollen wir im
nächsten Jahr sehr besonders
voranbringen auch das lohnt eine
Vertiefung wie das gehen kann und
natürlich ist es auch vernünftig darüber
zu diskutieren ob die Marktmechanismen
die festgestellten Marktpreise wirklich
richtig sind wir wissen ja gegenwärtig
gehen die Gaspreise runter auf den
Weltmärkten das muss sich auch noch mit
verstärkten Tempo hierzu hier in Europa
wieder spiegeln und deshalb ist es
wichtig auch das zu diskutieren zur
Solidarität haben wir alle Kraft mit dem
Recovery fand den wir zur Bekämpfung der
corona-pandemie aufgelegt haben ist eine
ganz starke finanzielle Möglichkeit für
Europa da zu handeln das haben wir
während der Kurve 19 Pandemie
ausprobiert die ist ja auch noch nicht
zu Ende aber wir wissen dass ein großer
Teil der Mittel die wir dort mobilisiert
haben noch gar nicht ausgegeben sind wo
es jetzt noch darauf ankommt zu
investieren in die Digitalisierung aber
auch in die
Infrastruktur zu Energieerzeugung damit
wir auf erneuerbare Energien setzen
können und uns mehr unabhängig machen
können diese Mittel jetzt zu
mobilisieren in der nächsten Krise die
der letzten folgt das ist eine gute
Möglichkeit wir haben normalerweise ja
doch das Phänomen dass viele der
Konjunkturprogramme erst greifen wenn
die Krisen vorbei sind jetzt ist leider
das Unglück da das auf die 19 Pandemie
der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine gefolgt ist aber die Mittel sind
da und können jetzt unmittelbar schon
während dieser nächsten Herausforderung
wirken das gilt auch für das Programm
Repower EU auf das dass die Kommission
vorgelegt hat und worüber sich die
Finanzminister verständigt haben also
die Möglichkeit zu solidarischem Handeln
ist da und ich bin sicher dass wir Wege
definieren werden die wir dann
beschreiten können und das ist auch
etwas wofür wir uns sehr einsetzen
können
als Deutschland momentan von vielen
Kollegen geboren worden glauben sie dass
ein atmender preisbegriffen
es ist ganz klar dass Deutschland sehr
solidarisch gehandelt hat ich glaube
dass ich sagen kann dass als jemand der
den mit Recovery fand der uns aus der
Kurve 19 Pandemie geführt hat entwickelt
hat sich auch da ein ganz gutes Urteil
darüber ablegen kann wie man das machen
kann und wir sind jetzt ja weiter dabei
diese Instrumente die wir schon haben zu
nutzen und sie jetzt auch für diese
Krise einzusetzen Deutschland
unterstützt wie viele andere Länder auch
seine Bürger und Bürger mit
belastungspaketen und auch mit der
Mobilisierung eines
abwehrschirms den wir errichtet haben
und der in diesem Woche das Parlament in
Deutschland fast passieren wird mit dem
wir in der Lage sind in diesem den
nächsten und dem übernächsten Jahre
unsere Bürger und Bürger auch bei den
gastpreisen zum Beispiel zu unterstützen
und bei den Strompreisen wenn man das
auf diese Zeit umrechnet ist das genau
das gleiche was Frankreich macht was
Italien macht das Spanien macht und
viele andere Länder es passt also ganz
gut zu dem was wir hier in Europa auch
an vielen anderen Stellen sehen und ist
dann ja auch eine gute Grundlage fürs
zusammenarbeiten und ansonsten das will
ich ganz gerne noch mal sagen es ist
auch so dass wir natürlich gucken müssen
dass wir das was wir entscheiden so
einrichten dass es funktioniert niemand
möchte ja Beschlüsse fassen wo es
hinterher theoretisch gut ist aber kein
Gast gibt das muss auch miteinander
hingekriegt werden
können Sie diese Kritik annehmen dass
Deutschland Westeuropa nicht ausreichend
unterstützt
die unterstützen Europa sehr nachhaltig
der nachdrücklich auch 20% des Haushalts
normalerweise und wir zeigen sehr viele
Solidarität entwickeln entsprechende
Mechanismen wir bei der corona-krise wir
haben da Instrumente entwickelt und
bereitgestellt für den Po den
wiederaufbaufonds eine gute Möglichkeit
zusammenzuarbeiten auch in der vor uns
liegenden Zeit denn die meisten Fonds
die wir aufgebaut haben für die
Wiederaufbau Zwecke haben ihren Zweck
gehabt ihren Sinn gehabt und geht in die
richtige Richtung
angetreten in Zeiten großer
internationaler wirtschaftliche
Instabilität
Privatpersonen und Unternehmen fragten
sich für Sie Ihre Rechnungen bezahlen
konnten der Krieg in Ukraine bedroht die
Sicherheit auf dem gesamten Kontinent
niedriges Wachstum hat unser Land zu
lange zurückgehalten ich bin von der
konservativen Partei gewählt worden um
das zu ändern wir haben energieprogramme
entwickelt und internationalen
Versicherung unsere Maßnahmen ergriffen
wir haben Ehrgeiz gezeigt unsere
Absichten verkündet für eine mit
geringen Steuern versehene
wachstumsorientierte Wirtschaft
angesichts der Lage die die entstanden
hat kann ich den Mandat nicht gerecht
werden für das nicht die Konzept für
Partei benannt hat ich habe deshalb mit
seiner Majestät dem König gesprochen und
dem mitgeteilt dass sich zurücktrete als
Führerin der konservativen Partei ich
bin heute morgen mit dem Vorsitzenden
des 19:20 mit ihr zusammen getroffen wir
werden in der nächsten Woche über einen
nationale Wahl besprechen wir bleiben
auf dem Weg unser Steuerprogramm
durchzusetzen und die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität des die nationale Sicherheit
aufrecht zu erhalten ich werde als
Premierministerin im Amt bleiben bis ein
Nachfolger gewählt ist dankeschön
aus der eine ampelfraktion der lautet ja
verehrte Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer so
ist das manchmal wenn sich die
Ereignisse überschlagen sie haben es
gemerkt wir haben zunächst den Bundestag
verlassen weil sich ja die Staats- und
Regierungschefs in Brüssel treffen heute
um den ja richtigen Weg durch die
Energiekrise zu suchen und sich darüber
zu verständigen und wir wollten ihn
natürlich hier anschauen von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz dort zeigen
heute morgen gab es ja noch von Olaf
Scholz eine Regierungserklärung vor
diesem Europäischen Rat und jetzt wie
gesagt die Ankunft und dann trat
tatsächlich ja gab es die Eilmeldung und
dann voll zog sich das ja sehr schnell
in London dass die britische
Premierministerin Trust ja zu ihren
Rücktritt angekündigt hat das wollten
wir Ihnen natürlich auch zeigen übrigens
zum Thema Brüssel werden wir sie auch
weiter auf dem laufenden halten gegen 15
Uhr 20 15 Uhr wird es hier im jeden Tag
eine längere
abstimmungsunterbrechung geben und dann
werden wir Sie darüber informieren was
es Neues rund um den Europäischen Rat in
Brüssel gibt jetzt im Moment sind wir
hier in der Debatte es gibt einen Antrag
der afd-fraktion auf Einsetzung einer
orcad-kommission Sicherstellung der
Energieversorgung wir hören wieder in
die Debatte rein es spricht Michael
Kruse von der FDP-Fraktion
unsere Unterstützung sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
jetzt sind wir ja aber in einer ernsten
Situation und weil wir in einer ernsten
Situation in der Energiepolitik sind
machen wir ja hier fast im
Wochenrhythmus neue Gesetze nun frage
ich mich was soll denn eigentlich eine
solche an cap-kommission bringen die
würde ja zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt genau
gar nichts entscheiden sie würde ja in
die Zukunft gerichtet erstmal eingesetzt
dann Empfehlungen arbeiten dann müssen
wir diskutieren ob wir das machen und
dann müsste das umgesetzt werden jetzt
könnten da ja mit so einer Kommission
kluge Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler drin sitzen die könnten
uns ja das empfehlen was andere kluge
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
uns schon längst empfehlen schauen Sie
mal in den ipc-bericht ich weiß es bei
ihm da drüben nicht so beliebt aber da
sitzen ja nur bei kluge
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
zusammen die empfehlen uns hier etwas
die empfehlen uns ja etwas und dann wäre
es jetzt eigentlich wenn sie sagen es
braucht eine weitere Kommission dann
wäre es ja an ihnen zu erklären warum
die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse die
bisher erarbeitet worden sind in dieser
Welt zum Thema Energie warum die nicht
ausreichend und warum wir jetzt eine
eigene Kommission brauchen mit der wir
uns dann beschäftigen anstatt die
wichtigen Gesetze zu machen die wir
aktuell gerade machen nein meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das nicht die
richtige Reihenfolge ist nicht der
richtige Angang und ich habe auch nicht
den Eindruck dass sie zu den Zielen die
wir hier erreichen wollen miteinander
auch tatsächlich etwas beitragen wollen
[Applaus]
und es ist auch in gewisser Weise
bezeichnend ja keine eigenen Vorschläge
hier jetzt vorzutragen sondern
stattdessen einen Arbeitskreis gründen
zu wollen also wenn ich eigene
Vorschläge eigene Ideen habe dann lasse
ich mich dafür ja in ein Parlament
wählen wir haben das so gemacht deswegen
sind wir jetzt in der Verantwortung für
dieses Land sie haben sich nur in dieses
Parlament wählen lassen um gegen das zu
sein was hier die Mehrheit möchte dabei
wünsche ich Ihnen keinen Erfolg und
deswegen beende ich meine Rede mit dem
Hinweis darauf dass wir die
Energiepolitik in diesem Land in die
richtige Richtung führen und ihre
Expertenkommission nicht brauchen
herzlichen Dank
und für die unionfraktion hat das Wort
Carsten Müller
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren die afd-fraktion will
also eine onkette-kommission einsetzen
es gelingt ihr offensichtlich schon
nicht die eigene Fraktion von dieser
etwas
abwegigen Idee zu überzeugen als ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender während des
zeitungsstudiums in den hinteren
aufgewacht ist gab bei ihrem
Fraktionsgeschäftsführer den riffels
können nicht sein weil das bei einem
eigenen Antrag nur vier Leute im Saal
sein so war es meine Damen und Herren
und ehrlich gezeigt ehrlich gesagt das
beschreibt erstens die Relevanz des
Themas dass sie aufrufen und zweitens
den Zustand ihrer Fraktion ziemlich
treffen
es nimmt auch nicht weiter wunderbar
wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut was sie
ergründen wollen dann nehme ich mal den
einen Punkt den sie gleich auf der
ersten Seite Ausführen dieser
onkelett-kommission soll nämlich unter
anderem die Darstellung des Anteils
sogenannter regenerativer Energien an
der gesamtenergieproduktion in
Deutschland Europa unterwegs
ich empfehle Ihnen bei Gelegenheit mal
Blick auf statista.de oder ähnliches da
können sich die ganze Kommissionsarbeit
sparen da steht das nämlich schon also
insofern zeigt das so in etwa ihre
Gedankengänge meine Damen und Herren ich
werde Ihnen kurz noch mal auf die
Sprünge helfen
2021 lag der Anteil der Erneuerbaren am
Primärenergieverbrauch bei 16 Prozent am
bruttoentenergieverbrauch bei 19,7%
weite Teile der
der onkette kommissionsaufgabe haben wir
damit erledigt jedenfalls die die Sie
sich vorstellen aber meine Damen und
Herren nicht nur das ist absonderlich
wir haben in dieser Woche zum Thema
Energiepolitik noch einiges
absonderliches erlebt beispielsweise
beim Blick auf die Ampel Koalition also
es ist ein anderer Stelle heute schon
angesprochen worden
wenn jemand seine Autorität besonders
betonen muss und erst recht wenn er sie
aufschreiben muss dann ist es mit dieser
behaupteten Autorität meistens nicht so
weit her das Zitat von Franz Müntefering
der gesagt hat zum Thema richtigen
Kompetenz wird das macht in einer
Koalition der weiß dass die Koalition am
Ende zu Ende ist ist ebenfalls mehrfach
heute vorgebracht worden und es ist wie
vieles von Franz Müntefering richtig
jedenfalls ist es sozusagen die
vorletzte Maßnahme vor einem
Misstrauensvotum die dann noch bleibt
das auch die vollmundigen Begründung
beispielsweise des Klima und
energieministers offensichtlich relativ
wenig zählen das sehen wir daran was die
Kollegin Nestl gesagt hat und wir sehen
es auch daran dass die grüne
Bundestagsfraktion sagt
dieser Herr Scholz der hat zwar einen
richtigen Kompetenz in seinem Kabinett
aber was wir als grüne Fraktion machen
das ist eine ganz andere Frage und wir
machen erstmal nichts damit sind sie in
guter Tradition dieser Ampelkoalition
sie machen nämlich nichts und lassen die
Menschen alleine meine Damen und Herren
will noch mal einige andere Themen
dieser zur Energiepolitik dieser sie
geben sich einen anderen Namen aber in
Wahrheit sind sie die
rückblickskoalition
geben also halten wir mal einsfest Nord
Stream 1 waren rot-grünes Projekt die
Energie- und gaspeicher sind von einem
SPD-Minister mit dessen großer
Unterstützung an Russland verhöckert
worden und das gestatten Sie mir mal
also ich bin ehrlich gesagt fassungslos
das in einer Situation wie der momentan
dieser Herr Scholz
wichtige vitale Infrastruktur an China
für Höckern will und ehrlich gesagt das
zeigt doch den Zustand ihrer ihrer
Koalition dem ist das egal was
sechsfach-ministerien sagen dem ist das
egal ich bin mal gespannt ob er
den von ihnen getragenen Ministern ein
weiteres Mal sagt er hat die
Richtlinienkompetenz und er und er
verhöckert Hamburger Infrastruktur mein
Vorredner kommt ja aus Hamburg so mir
nichts dir nichts an chinesischen
staatskonzept ich bin gespannt
und dann gucken wir noch mal auf das
Thema gucken wir noch mal auf das Thema
[Musik]
weil sie ja sich gerne mit Rückblicken
auf 16 oder 17 Jahre beschäftigen gucken
wir mal nur ein Jahr zurück und wir
blättern ihren Koalitionsvertrag durch
und wir lesen an 12 14 16 Stellen dass
sie den Gaseinsatz massiv ausbauen
wollen massiv ausbauen wollen im
Gegensatz dazu lesen wir ein Wort gar
nicht in dem rot-grünen Ampel Vertrag
das Wort Wasserkraft und es ist noch
nicht lange her als wir uns hier mit
einer Novelle des erneuerbaren Energien
mit einer Novelle des Erneuerbaren
energiengesetzes beschäftigt haben indem
sie und sie und sie die kleine
Wasserkraft ausfahren wollten und es war
und es war ausschließlich die Initiative
die Initiative der Union und einer
breiten Öffentlichkeit die das
verhindert hat und das ist richtig so
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
noch mal zum Mitschreiben die Ampel will
ein Gesetz beschließen die Ampel für ein
Gesetz beschließen bei dem sie überhaupt
gar nicht weiß welche Rechtsfolgen sich
daraus ableiten und wie das auf den
Energiemarkt wird sie zögern und das
Thema AKW-Laufzeiten hatten wir hier
schon angesprochen wir brauchen dazu
will ich zum Thema dieser Debatte heute
zurückkommen wir brauchen keine
onkel-kommission wie ist die
auch praktisch nicht teilnehmende
afd-fraktion hier vorschicht sondern was
wir bräuchten wäre eine entschlossene
kluge handlungsfähige Bundesregierung
dafür gibt es in diesem Haus leider
keine Mehrheit
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Timon gremmels
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das ist schon
mal ein Ding ne Kernzeit am Donnerstag
eine wichtige debattenzeit im Deutschen
Bundestag die AFD stellt einen Antrag
und zu Beginn sind vier Abgeordnete
afd-fraktion da das nenne ich mal
wirklich auch an die ZuschauerInnen
die Debatte das finde ich schon
Arbeitsverweigerung gut bei dem Antrag
wenn wir das jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt
zu peinlich als afd-fraktion anwesend zu
sein aber gut das müssen Sie für sich
entscheiden ich erinnere mich noch am
Beginn der letzten Periode wo sie
sozusagen hier Bilder
gefaked haben indem sie morgens
halblehre abgeordnetenränge der anderen
fotografiert haben und jetzt müssen wir
mal ein Bild von ihren Abgeordneten
machen sie verweigern die Arbeit und
zwar nicht nur hier im Haus sondern auch
die inhaltliche Arbeit meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren weil
auch da wenn man jetzt den Antrag die
Überschrift liest Sicherstellung der
Energieversorgung einer okay-kommission
wer sollte denn der was gegen haben es
klingt ja im ersten Moment als etwas na
endlich ist ja mal was vernünftiges da
und dann habe ich mir die Arbeit gemacht
und habe wirklich das gelesen was sie da
aufgeschrieben haben und es ist nicht
nur lieber Michael Kruse Sachstand von
April Mai diesen Jahres das stimmt es
werden ja sogar Quellen angeführt in der
Energiepolitik von 1999 sie beziehen
sich in einer Fußnote auf eine Studie
von 1999 23 Jahre her das ist in der
Energiepolitik sozusagen eine halbe
Ewigkeit wenn das sozusagen die
Grundlage ihres Arbeitens ist und auch
ihrer Positionierung energiepolitisch
von heute sagt das doch alles über sie
aus sie sind gar nicht auf der Höhe der
Zeit meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren und ehrlich gesagt ist es nicht
die Aufgabe des Deutschen Bundestages
und auch des Steuerzahlers jetzt hier
eine Fortbildungsveranstaltung zu machen
für die afd-fraktion das wollen sie aus
ihren fraktionsmitteln bezahlen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und Sie
sollten es auch mal tun weil sie
brauchen in Sachen Energiepolitik klar
eine Fortbildung sie sind nicht auf der
Höhe der Zeit wissen Sie was die
preiswerteste günstigste sicherste Form
der Energieerzeugung ist preiswert das
ist die Photovoltaik das ist die derzeit
günstigste Form der Energieerzeugung das
ist kein Unsinn das ist wissenschaftlich
evident das können sie gerne nachlesen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und sie ihre
verweigert doch die Realität sie
beziehen sich auf Studien von 1999 sie
sind gar nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und vor allem weil sie jetzt von der die
Industrialisierung Phasen das stimmt
doch auch nicht die Energiewende ist der
größte Jobmotor wenn wir sie konsequent
ansetzen dezentrale erneuerbare Energien
schaffen Arbeitsplätze schaffen gute
Arbeitsplätze und zwar nicht nur in
zentralen Standorten wie das bei
Kohlekraftwerken der Fall ist sondern
dezentral in unseren Kommunen da sind
die solartüre die Dachdecker die
Anlagenbauer für Windkraftanlagen für
Gasanlagen die Händler die die Wartung
vornehmen all das schafft gute
Arbeitsplätze meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren wenn wir Energiewende in
Deutschland richtig und konsequent
machen ist das etwas was uns auch auf
dem Weltmarkt voranbringt das bringt uns
voran und da gibt es Leute die
nacheifern was wir gemacht haben und die
große Gefahr ist doch dass wir die wir
doch in den letzten 20 Jahren wirklich
auch viel Geld in die Hand genommen
haben auch die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher über die ig-umlage um eine
Technologie die Erneuerbaren
voranzubringen heranzuführen die
Weltmarkt dass wir jetzt die Gefahr
machen wenn wir jetzt auf die Bremse
treten dann wird es weiter so sein das
Wissen dass Industriearbeitsplätze
abwandern nicht nur nach China sondern
mittlerweile auch in die USA weil da die
Rahmenbedingungen mittlerweile viel
besser passieren deswegen ist es der
falsche Weg jetzt hier ein Stoppschild
aufzusetzen wir müssen die Energiewende
beschleunigen wir müssen die
voranbringen und wir müssen auch
europäisch Antworten auf den Inflation
reduction Act von beiden schätzen damit
wir zukunftsfähiger Arbeitsplätze
Forschung und Entwicklung in den
erneuerbaren Energien hier in
Deutschland behalten und hier ansiedeln
meine seitwerten Damen und Herren das
ist die Zukunft und dafür für diese
Zukunft steht diese Ampelkoalition oder
brauchen Sie sich auch überhaupt gar
keine Sorgen zu machen und keine
falschen Hoffnungen zu machen diese
Ampelkoalition arbeitet im Bereich der
Energiepolitik eng und gut zusammen wir
haben mich bei überschlagen über 13
Gesetze schon auf den Weg gebracht meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren ersten
halben Jahr und wir räumen hinterher ein
Altmaier hinterher auch das gehört zur
Wahrheit dazu lieber Carsten Müller sie
müssen das auch für sich mal
rekapitulieren und sie müssten es auch
mal kritisch reflektieren wer hat denn
im letzten Jahr ist zugelassen dass
unsere garspeicher in Deutschland alle
leer sind das war Peter alt sie waren
leer wir mussten erst die Voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass sie gefüllt werden
wer war denn der zuständige Minister
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen gramling bitte
vielen Dank für die Zulassung der
Zwischenfrage Herr Kollege ich wollte
nur kurz nachfragen ob Ihnen bekannt ist
und was sie davon halten dass der
Wirtschaftsminister bei seiner groß
angekündigten
Eröffnungsbilanz war ja die Abrechnung
gemacht hat mit der Vorgängerregierung
dass er zu diesem Zeitpunkt nach wie vor
voll auf Gas gesetzt hat und keine
Anzeichen im Vergleich zum Bundeskanzler
hatte dass wir in ein gasproblem kommen
könnten also meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren auf ihre Frage zurückzukommen
in der Eröffnungsbilanz hat sich der
Minister auf ein paar Faktoren
beschränkt wir konnten in dieser Phase
ja nicht die kompletten 16 Jahre CDU
geführter Bundesregierung hier
beantworten das Thema Gas ist nach wie
vor eines und da wäre ich an ihrer
Stelle mal wirklich kleinere Brötchen
backen als CDU CSU-Fraktion schließlich
war es ja ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender und
ihr
Parteivorsitzender der noch im März
gefordert hat wir sollten sofort die
Gaspipeline schließen wir sollten
Ostrings 1 ab regeln dann hätten wir die
Speicher nicht vorher bekommen es waren
Robert Habeck es war die Koalition die
unidologisch und undogmatisch hier
Entscheidungen getroffen hat für die
deutsche Wirtschaft für die Menschen
damit die Speicher schnell gefüllt
werden und es ist uns viel Glück die
Speicher sind bei 95 Prozent jetzt
richtig voll das ist
sozialdemokratischer und Grüne und
fdp-regierungserfolge abzustehen wir wir
räumen Ihnen hinterher und wir räumen
Ihnen auch bei den lng-terminals
hinterher auch da hat der zuständige
Wirtschaftsminister in der letzten
Wahlperiode nicht dafür gesorgt dass wir
auch nur ein Terminal in Deutschland
bekommen auch das gehört zur Wahrheit
dazu
also meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wir müssen noch mal Fakten
anerkennen deutschland hat in Europa
kein einziges LNG Terminal und diese
Koalition räumt im hinterher indem wir
jetzt solche terminals in höchster
Geschwindigkeit ans Netz bringen damit
im Dezember noch die ersten LG Termin
jetzt hier angekommen als
Übergangstechnologie weil die Zukunft
gehört den Erneuerbaren wir müssen jetzt
investieren wir müssen jetzt die
Erneuerbaren ausbauen Windkraft in
Bayern jawoll schaffen sie 10h ab da tun
sie mehr für die Energiewende als jede
Diskussion Nummer Laufzeitverlängerung
wir brauchen eine massiven Ausbau der
Photovoltaik und weitere erneuerbaren
Energiequellen nur so gelingt es uns aus
der Krise zu kommen nachhaltig zu wirken
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und die
Menschen nicht alleine zu lassen diese
Koalition packt an in diesem Sinne glück
auf
Simon Kreml zwar das für die
SPD-Fraktion und jetzt folgt hier
Bernhard Hermann für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 grün er sitzt im Ausschuss
für Klimaschutz und Energie
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen ja ich weiß jetzt nicht so
recht ob ich mich geehrt fühlen soll das
mittlerweile die reihen sich wenigstens
etwas füllen aber es immer noch marginal
die Beteiligung gerade von denen die im
energieausschuss für das Thema zuständig
sind mit diesem Antrag hat die AFD
wieder mal bewiesen dass es ihr nicht
darum geht die Interessen der Menschen
zu vertreten viel mehr schüren sie aus
Partei taktischen Gründen Ängste in der
Bevölkerung leider von beiden
politischen Rändern wie wir heute
schmerzlich erfahren mussten das tut mir
weh als jemand der in Chemnitz lange
schon auch mit der Linken kooperiert
wenn sozialverantwortlich war das tut
wirklich weh von
verantwortungsvoller parlamentarische
Arbeit keine Spur dieser Antrag strotzt
von offensichtlichen handwerklichen
Mängeln trifft vor Falschaussagen wie
zum Beispiel der Aussage dass die
AKW-Betreiber sich nicht in der Lage
sehen ein striktbetrieb durchzuführen da
wir bereiten die AKW-Betreiber gerade
genau das vor und dann ist dieser Antrag
genau wie die afd-politik im allgemeinen
voller Widersprüche Mal wird gesagt dass
die Energiewende ein deutscher Sonderweg
sei an anderer Stelle dass die Energie
zum europäischen Grindel passe dann
spricht sie noch davon dass unsere
europäischen Nachbarn die deutsche
Energiewende kritisieren als Beleg
musste sie aber auf einen
Zeitungsartikel von 2013 zurückgreifen
mal fordert die AFD Erleichterung für
Solarstrom jetzt wieder das Ende der
Energiewende wie passt das alles
zusammen aber das ist den postfaktikern
der AFD doch egal
in zehn Monaten hat das
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz mehr als 50 Gesetze und
Verordnung auf den Weg gebracht die AFD
kriegt das nicht einmal hin diesen einen
Antrag der offensichtlich schon im
Frühling geschrieben wurde auf dem
neuesten Stand zu bringen bevor sie
ihnen ins parlamentarische Verfahren
einbringt qualitative Oppositionsarbeit
sieht anders aus
aber das erwarte ich auch nicht von
ihnen auch wenn sie anderswo immer so
tun
kein Wunder also dass die AFD sich
externe
externe Expertise wünscht um ihre
eigenen Fehler zu überdecken aber das
wird dir nicht helfen denn der
Populismus der AFD entbehrt jeglicher
faktischen seriösen wissenschaftlichen
Grundlage ja die Energiewende muss
kritisch hinterleuchtet und
möglicherweise auch nachjustiert werden
zum Beispiel können wir seit März nicht
weiterhin auf vermeintlich günstiges
Erdgas aus Russland setzen darum ist es
umso dringlicher die Erneuerbaren
auszubauen um Gaskraftwerke noch
seltener und mit weniger Gaseinsatz als
Backup nutzen zu können
und wir werden Erdgas schnellstmöglich
mit grünem Wasserstoff ersetzen und mit
flexibel eingesetztem Biogas und schon
ist das Problem lösbar wenn man es denn
möchte
mit dem vorliegenden Antrag will die AFD
jetzt die Aufgabe des Parlaments die
Regierung zu kontrollieren auf eine Art
Kommission abschieben wir alle in diesem
Hohen Haus haben die Arbeit der
Bundesregierung regelmäßig kritisch zu
prüfen dafür braucht es keine
entkettkommission der Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie hat in diesem
Jahr schon 36 Mal getagt und zu allen
Gesetzen wird in Anhörung breiter
Sachverstand hinzugezogen wenn man dabei
aber immer nur den Klimawandel leugnet
oder über angeblichen flatterstrom
Unsinn erzählt kann man natürlich aus
den Expertenanhörungen auch nichts
mitnehmen sonst aber kann man durchaus
die richtigen Schlüsse ziehen für
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidungen um
als ja nicht schlecht bezahlte
Abgeordnete nicht auch noch weitere
Steuergeld verschlingende Kommission
beschäftigen zu müssen
anstatt wie die AFD der Bevölkerung mit
populistischen Sprüchen was vorzumachen
hier das Blaue vom Himmel zu erzählen
sollten alle hier im Parlament einfach
verantwortungsbewusste Parlamentsarbeit
machen wir als ampelfraktion machen
genau das und arbeiten entschlossen
daran zum einen sicher und ohne
gravierende Verwerfung durch diese
Energiekrise zu kommen und da gibt es
große Erfolge die Speicher sind gefüllt
die Gaspreise sinken massiv im
Großhandel im Spotmarkt als auch im
Terminmarkt und wir arbeiten zum anderen
daran seit Beginn der Legislatur
ambitioniert auf eine sichere
klimaverträgliche und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung neu auszurichten
vielen Dank
Bernhard Herrmann war das von den Grünen
ja hat auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen
wie einige Rednerinnen und Redner da
darauf dass in diesem Antrag der AFD
handwerkliche Mängel stecken würden
Konrad Stockmeyer jetzt für die
Liberalen und Kollegen und insbesondere
auch die Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
wie ich seit einem Jahr neu im Bundestag
dabei sind
vielleicht geht es Ihnen auch so wie mir
dass ich mit einer gewissen Irritation
feststelle dass in diesem Hohen Haus ein
Satz gemieden wird wie der Teufel des
Weihwasser meidet der eigentlich gerade
in Krisenzeiten in den Zusammenhängen in
denen wir alle unterwegs sind in der
Familie im Verein im Betrieb in der
Hochschulgruppe in der azubi-gruppe eine
ganz große Rolle spielt es ist der Satz
wir schaffen das
und ich glaube es tut uns nicht gut dass
wir aus dem politischen Diskurs diesen
Satz völlig ausblenden weil er uns
gerade in Erinnerung ruft das in
schweren Zeiten das in schweren Zeiten
dieser Satz aufzeigt wir können das
schaffen auch wenn wir Umwege nehmen
müssen wenn wir auf Unvorhergesehenes
reagieren müssen und gerade wenn es
schwer wird
ihr Antrag
ihr Antrag atmet nur den Geist der
Vergangenheit sie verweigern sich einer
zukünftigen sicheren Energieversorgung
in Deutschland und in Europa und es geht
schon damit los dieser Satz wir schaffen
das kommt ihnen allein schon deswegen
nicht über die Lippen weil sie wir ja
nur ausgrenzens definieren können dieses
wir geht selbstverständlich über den
Rahmen einer Regierungskoalition in
Deutschland weit hinaus dieses wir
müssen wir angesichts des Angriffs von
von Putin auf Freiheit und Demokratie
mindestens europäisch wenn ich auch
transatlantisch denken lauter Aspekte
die man in ihrem Antrag völlig vermisst
worauf trifft man dagegen auf alle
Kamellen aus der Vergangenheit die durch
nichts gerechtfertigt sind sie kommen
beispielsweise bei den Windkraftanlagen
immer noch mit der mehr vom Infraschall
um die Ecke ich empfehle Ihnen mal im
Archiv der Frankfurter Allgemeinen
Zeitung im Natur- und wissenschaftsteil
von vor ein paar Monaten einen
kongressbericht nachzulesen wo einfach
noch mal aufgezeigt wurde dass der
Infraschall den sie beim Brustschwimmen
erzeugen wesentlich größer ist als das
was jede Windkraftanlage ausrichten kann
ich habe mir angewöhnt in Berliner
Sitzungswochen zweimal ein zwei mal
schwimmen zu gehen aber vielleicht
kommen sie auch noch auf die Idee das
verbieten zu wollen ich glaube sie
werden dafür keine Mehrheit kriegen
zweitens ist schon angesprochen worden
dass sie Entwicklungen der
Energiespeicher an ihnen völlig
Vorbeigehen denken Sie mal darüber nach
warum die eigentlich interessanten
Gesprächspartner dort mit Ihnen den
Kontakt nicht suchen ebenso fordern sie
Formen der Bürgerbeteiligung endlich mal
zu evaluieren denken sie mir denken Sie
mal darüber nach warum sie zum
Bürgerenergie Konvent der vor ein zwei
Wochen in Fulda stattgefunden hat und wo
ich mit Kollege hümpfer eingeladen war
warum sie dort nicht eingeladen worden
sind weil sich eben die die sich
bürgerschaftlich für die Energiewende
engagieren von ihnen rein gar nichts
versprechen
des Weiteren fordern sie dass eine
Energieversorgung in Angriff genommen
wird die Abhängigkeiten vermeidet und in
diesem Kontext herausschussvorsitzender
Klaus Ernst kann ich nur sagen dass wir
Ihre Einlassungen hier einmal mehr die
Sprache verschlagen sie fordern also mit
einem Regime ins Gespräch zu kommen das
Kamikaze Drohnen in diesen Tagen auf
Wohnhäuser in Kiew herabstürzen lässt
also ich weiß nicht welche
Dialogmöglichkeiten sich da auftun soll
es ist mir ein Rätsel
[Applaus]
des Weiteren fordern sie die
Auseinandersetzung mit
wissenschaftlichen Theorien ich kann
Ihnen nur sagen es hindert sie niemand
daran wir Freie Demokraten sind nicht
bereit weitere Steuergelder für eine
omelett-kommission bereitzustellen nur
weil sie sich nicht sinnvoll mit sich
selber beschäftigen können
wenn ich zu Hause in Mannheim unterwegs
bin auf den Marktplätzen dann geben mir
Menschen mit diesen Satz wir schaffen
das noch mit einem anderen klar Kollege
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
noch wir müssen das schaffen und das
werden wir schaffen es kostet uns Kraft
aber wir kriegen das hin vielen Dank
ja und während der Rede von Konrad
Stockmeyer gab es einen Wechsel in der
Sitzungsleitung Wolfgang Kubicki der
Bundestagsvizepräsident leitet jetzt die
Sitzung und Konrad Stockmeier von der
FDP hat ja daran erinnert an diesen Satz
wir schaffen das Olaf Scholz heute
morgen hatte nicht diesen Satz gesagt
sondern hat gesagt gemeinsam kommen wir
wohl durch diesen Winter das hat er
heute morgen in dieser
Regierungserklärung vor dem Europäischen
Rat gesagt jetzt Jonas Geister für die
Union ihren Antrag gelesen ausführlich
und war bei ihren einleitenden Worten
durchaus sehr überrascht weil von den
sieben Minuten Redezeit die sie hatten
haben sie sechs Minuten auf alles
geschimpft was es gibt und haben sich
mit in einer Minute mit ihrem eigenen
Antrag beschäftigt das ist also ich habe
mir dann durchaus auch die Frage
gestellt ob Sie Ihren Antrag selbst
gelesen haben der eine oder andere
Kollege hat darauf hingewiesen dass der
Antrag wohl nicht die der aktuellste ist
die meisten Fußnoten sind vom 21 April
danach folgt der Zwang der 12 Mai und
mir ist das ganze eigentlich nur
aufgefallen weil ich irgendwann auf den
Satz gestoßen bin 35 Prozent unseres
Gases kommen aus Russland also jeder der
in diesem Haus im letzten halben Jahr
aufgepasst hat weiß dass wir davon seit
langem weit entfernt sind weil aus
Russland wird zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
genau gar nichts mehr geliefert und das
schon seit September das heißt wenn
jemand seit Anfang September von ihnen
sich mit diesem Antrag beschäftigt hätte
dann hätten sie irgendwann mitbekommen
dass die Russen uns kein Gas mehr
liefern und dass das im Übrigen schon
lange geplant gewesen ist das weiß jeder
der eine Energiepolitik gemacht hat im
letzten halben oder im letzten
Dreivierteljahr ich komme aus einer
Region wo die bayerisch thüringenische
Glasindustrie zu Hause ist die
energieintensiven Unternehmen in meiner
Heimat haben sich das erste Mal an mich
im November dezember 2021 gewendet mit
dem Satz wir haben ein unglaubliches
Problem Energie auf sofortmärkten
einzukaufen da gibt es nichts mehr
mittlerweile wissen wir dass die Russen
das komplette Jahr 2021 die Gasspeicher
nicht vollgefüllt haben und sie haben
den Spotmarkt nicht bedient das alles
waren unmittelbare Kriegsvorbereitungen
Putins und wenn man diesen Antrag liest
wenn man ihren Antrag liest mit der
einen oder anderen Formulierung dann
kommt genau das dabei raus was man auch
als schwurbeln begreifen kann sie
schreiben hier davon
Gesundheitsrisiken Elektrosmog also
alles was Menschen die sich aluhüte
aufsetzen wo wir denen sie Angst haben
sie bedienen damit narrative die wir
eigentlich alle gemeinsam überwunden
haben weil jeden in diesem Haus sollte
es darum gehen dass Deutschland eine
gute Energieversorgung aktuell und auch
in der Zukunft hat
und wenn man ganz ehrlich ist machen sie
damit das was ihre Fraktionsvorsitzende
auf ihren Social Media Kanälen macht
kann mich erinnern dass alles Weidel
irgendwann die Woche über suggeriert hat
die USA hätten die pipelions gesprengt
es macht sie nicht wortwörtlich sondern
da werden dann narrative in den Raum
gestellt Fragen gestellt nach dem Motto
jetzt hört doch mal hin und schaut doch
einfach mal zu Herr Kollege erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage des Kollegen Ernst
selbstverständlich
Klaus Ernst von der Linken
danke dass Sie die Frage zulassen sie
haben jetzt gerade gesagt sie hätten
schon im mit ihrem Kollegen der
Glasindustrie in Bayern schon im letztes
Jahr
besprochen dass
da die russische eigentlich voll machen
jetzt war es so dass ich im September
Oktober eine anfrageende Bundesregierung
geschrieben habe weil das ja auch
behauptet wurde in der Bundesrepublik ob
es zutreffend sei oder ob die
Bundesregierung Hinweise hat dass
Russland seine Verträge mit Deutschland
hinsichtlich der Lieferung von Gas nicht
erfüllt
die Antwort der Bundesregierung war nein
es liegen keine Hinweise vor dass
Russland zu diesem damaligen Zeitpunkt
seine Verträge nicht erfüllt
so erstens zweitens es war das eine
Bundesregierung die von der CDU geführt
war gehen Sie davon aus dass sie dort
belogen wurde ich bin gerne in den
Bereichen in die Unterlagen zur
Verfügung zu stellen denn ich habe mich
auch gewundert aufgrund der Debatte die
stattgefunden hat auf der einen Seite
und aufgrund der eindeutigen Ansage der
Bundesregierung
das war nicht so jetzt gibt es natürlich
eine andere eine andere Möglichkeit dass
irgendwie Gas zu wenig bestellt worden
wäre jedenfalls liegt nicht an den
Verträgen die die Bundesregierung mit
Russland gemacht hat insofern würde ich
ableiten würden sie mit der zustimmen
dass bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt Russland
vertragsgemäß geliefert hat
also ganz ganz grundsätzlich das können
Sie
Kollege Ernstes können Sie im Nachhinein
im Protokoll meiner Rede nachschauen ich
habe gesagt dass die Russen im dritten
und vierten also nicht drittes Quartal
haben November Dezember gesagt die
Mengen die sie auf die spotmärkte
geliefert haben massiv begrenzt haben
und dass wir im Nachhinein wissen dass
auch die Gasspeicher nicht aufgefüllt
worden sind was ich zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt keiner angehört hat so nein
vertragsgemäß
sondern ich habe gesagt das wo die
Russen das wo die Russen
verpflichtet gewesen sind haben sie zu
diesem Zeitpunkt gemacht aber sie haben
nicht geliefert auf dem Spotmarkt und
damit haben die Russen das komplette
Energiesystem bei uns destabilisiert das
sind unmittelbare Vorbereitungen eines
wirtschaftskriegs gewesen und dass das
mit den gasspeichern keinem aufgefallen
ist das wissen wir mittlerweile alle die
wir Energiepolitik seit einem
Dreivierteljahr machen das heißt wenn
sie jetzt versuchen zu suggerieren und
genau das tun sie mit ihrer
Zwischenbemerkung dass die Russen alles
richtig gemacht hätten ist es falsch
weil wir waren unmittelbaren
Kriegsvorbereitungen ausgesetzt
bei mir war die erste die sich gemeldet
haben die Glasindustrie wir haben viel
gerungen um Lösungen wir haben immer
wieder versucht
Möglichkeiten zu Unterstützung der
Industrie zu finden
im Nachhinein ist da leider zu wenig
passiert und genau das ist jetzt auch
das Grundproblem mit dem Antrag zur
Einsetzung einer oncat-kommission weil
wenn wir uns über Energiewende
unterhalten dann wissen wir alle dass
der Faktor Zeit das schwierigste in der
aktuellen Situation überhaupt ist wir
haben nämlich keine Zeit und egal wie
schnell man eine ok-kommission
durchführt am Ende brauchen Sie
mindestens zwei Jahre um Lösungen zu
präsentieren diese zwei Jahre haben wir
aber nicht die ersten die sich an uns
gewendet haben waren die
energieintensiven Unternehmen die
nächsten die gekommen sind waren die
kleinen Mittelständler die ihre Strom
Gasverträge für das kommende Jahr
abgeschlossen haben und mittlerweile
betrifft diese Krise jeden einzelnen
privaten sie alle wissen aus ihren
Bürgersprechstunden wie die Menschen auf
uns zugehen ich habe
vier Wochen Gespräch mit einer
Krankenschwester geführt die mir am
eigenen Haus wohnt in der großen Wohnung
alleinerziehend mit ihrem Kindern die
überlegt sich in die kleine Wohnung
umzuziehen weil sie ihre Energiekosten
nicht mehr Fragen kann ich habe vor drei
Wochen ein Gespräch mit einem Brauer aus
Rödental geführt der mir erklärt hat wie
er in seiner Gaststätte in Zukunft
Kosten anders umlegen muss Anfang des
Jahres hat der Sauerbraten 15 Euro
gekostet wenn er die Energiekosten
umlegen muss ist er bei 20 Euro das kann
sich bei uns in der Region keiner mehr
leisten es kann sich niemand leisten die
Menschen in diesem Land haben Angst und
fürchten sich
und dass wir alle zumindest auf diesem
Teil des Hauses die Ängste der Menschen
ernst nehmen glaube ich ist unbestritten
aber wir haben eine andere Wahrnehmung
in dem was richtig und falsch ist und wo
gehandelt werden müsste und das ist
jetzt der Vorwurf den sie sich gefallen
lassen müssen wir haben vier Monate mit
ihnen gerungen ob die Wasserkraft
weitergefordert wird sie haben sieben
Monate herumgetan ob der biogast Deckel
aufgehoben wird wir haben im Februar das
erste Mal angeregt lass doch die
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen prüftscheid
wir haben hätten im Februar die Chance
gehabt die drei Atome einer die vom Netz
gegangen sind wieder hochzufahren das
ist der Vorwurf den sie sich gefallen
lassen müssen weil es bei Energie eben
auch leider um Ideologien geht und
Ideologien sind in dieser Situation
völlig fehl am Platze die Menschen im
Land haben Angst das ist die
Krankenschwester das ist der Brauer das
sind die zehntausenden in der Industrie
um ihr um ihre Arbeitsplätze fürchten
und vor allen Dingen ist es jeder
einzelne der nicht mehr weiß wie er
seine Strom- und Gasrechnung im nächsten
Jahr zahlen soll und für die Menschen
daheim ist es eben keine Lösung zu sagen
dass wir irgendwann im April einen
gaspreisdeckel kriegen sondern den
bräuchten die genauso wie die Industrie
im Januar überlegen Sie sich was sie tun
helfen sie den Menschen möglichst sofort
der Faktor Zeit ist entscheidend
deswegen werden wir Ihren Antrag nach
der Überweisung auch ablehnen aber sie
sind genauso herausgefordert zu handeln
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege das Geister war
das für die Unionsfraktion und jetzt hat
aus den Reihen der Ampelkoalition
Gelegenheit darauf zu erwidern der
Abgeordnete Robin eine Mesa Rosch für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren wer in dieser Krisen
geschüttelten Welt langfristig sicher
Strom aus der Steckdose bekommen will
braucht die Energiewende und braucht
100% erneuerbare Energien die AFD will
scheinbar über die Energiewende reden so
wie ich Ihren Antrag lese deswegen sage
ich reden wir über die Energiewende das
mache ich gern es ist nur schade finde
ich dass sie intellektuell immer bei der
Erkenntnis stehen bleiben das
Überraschung nachts die Sonne nicht
scheint und manchmal kein Wind weht
deswegen behaupten sie die Energiewende
könnte nicht funktionieren weil es da
Solaranlagen und weil es da
Windkraftanlagen gibt danke sage ich
dass sie mir die Zeit schenken dass ich
hier das Gegenteil erklären darf
wo sie sich immer irren ist bei dem
Begriff Grundlast den verwenden Sie
einmal falsch und lassen sich davon in
die Irre treiben sie sagen die
erneuerbaren Energien werden nicht
grundlastfähig dass es eben teils falsch
und wie gesagt teils irreführend der
Begriff ist hier gar nicht der relevante
ich will Ihnen erklären was entscheidend
ist
entscheidend ist dass in unserem
Stromnetz immer so viel Strom ist dass
wir genügend das in unserem Stromnetz
genauso viel Strom ist wie wir in dem
Moment verbrauchen das ist wichtig und
dem Stromnetz ist es an der Stelle erst
mal egal aus welchem Kraftwerk dieser
Strom kommt ob das jetzt grundlastfähig
ist oder nicht also müssen wir uns die
Frage stellen können wir in Zukunft mit
erneuerbaren Energien immer genügend
Strom ins Netz kriegen und die ganz
kurze Antwort ist ja
der Strombedarf übrigens das
vernachlässigen sie auch immer mit ihrem
sehr schwarz-weiß denkt die Sonne
scheint die Sonne scheint nicht die die
Antwort ist beinhaltet auch der
Strombedarf in Deutschland schwankt über
den Tag und das Schöne ist die
Solarenergie zum Beispiel schwankt nicht
wir brauchen nachts deutlich weniger
Strom als tagsüber und das
vernachlässigen sie permanent
dann kommen sie noch mit ihrem Winter da
sage ich ja im Winter scheint die Sonne
weniger aber dafür wählt im Winter mehr
Wind die erneuerbaren Energien sind wenn
ich das sagen darf intelligenter als sie
und deswegen ist das Problem kleiner als
die das immer darstellen man könnte
jetzt fragen natürlich gibt es da noch
eine Herausforderung auf die will ich
auch eingehen aber man könnte jetzt
fragen und das tun sie auch nein ist es
nicht einfacher überall AKWs und
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz zu hängen die
Pumpen dann irgendwie was auch nicht
stimmt zuverlässig immer Energie ins
Netz und ich sage Ihnen einfacher ist
nicht immer besser die fossilen Energien
und die Atomkraft sind teuer die
günstigste Art Energie zu erzeugen sind
die erneuerbaren Energien zweitens die
fossilen Energien zerstören unseren
Planeten atomisch strahlt das passiert
uns mit erneuerbaren Energien nicht
drittens die fossilen Energien machen
uns abhängig häufig von Diktaturen
viertens und da kommt Maria Fetisch der
grundlastfähigkeit ins Spiel die
Atomkraftwerke grätschen uns gerne in
die erneuerbaren Energien rein das tun
sie weil wir Atomkraftwerke nicht
einfach an und ausschalten können was
wir stattdessen machen müssen ist die
Erneuerbaren runter zu vom Netz zu
nehmen und das ist dämlich weil die ja
viel günstiger sind als das was sie da
laufen lassen wollen sie reden über
Ideologie dabei haben wir die
intelligente Lösungen sie haben diesen
Fetisch an diesen
grundlastfähigkeitsbegriff den sie noch
gar nicht verstanden haben ich habe also
gezeigt es lohnt sich ein Netz mit 100
Prozent an neuen Bahnen erneuerbaren
Energien zu betreiben jetzt ist die
Frage haben nein ich möchte die Frage
nicht dran nehmen danke ich möchte
nämlich Antworten geben und die kurze
Antwort ist kann man im Netz mit
erneuerbaren Energie betreiben ja die
lange Antwort passt nicht in diese Rede
weil Energieversorgung komplexer ist als
die Parolen die sie permanent raushauen
deswegen die mittellange die Antwort
Grundlast ist hier nicht der relevante
Begriff googeln sie lieber
residialast da geht es darum um dieses
Delta zwischen solaren Windenergie und
der Energie die wir sonst noch brauchen
aber sie vergessen dann dass wir
Pumpspeicherkraftwerke haben und haben
können dass wir Wasserkraft haben und
dass wir Zukunft und das müssen wir eben
tun mit grünem Wasserstoff auch Energie
ins Netz speisen und darum muss es gehen
Netze intelligent zu betreiben und
deswegen und das sage ich auch an die
CDU dieser gratis Mut sich selber dann
so ein bisschen
halbherzig die Energiewende ans Gewehr
zu helfen darum geht es nicht die
Energiewende ist nicht mal wenn es
genehm ist sondern es keine
Bürgerinitiative gibt die dagegen ist
ein Windkraftrad oder eine
Photovoltaikanlage aufzustellen wir
brauchen genügend und wir brauchen die
Netze dafür weil wenn wir diesen Strom
in Zukunft intelligenter verteilen
müssen brauchen wir andere Netze weil es
stand heute dass es auch an Ihre Adresse
wichtig wir Strom haben den wir weg
Regeln müssen den wir gar nicht ins Netz
reinkriegen und deswegen gehört zur
Energiewende dass wir die Netze ausbauen
und deswegen gehört es dazu dass
Konservative Ministerpräsidenten
aufhören den Netzausbau auszubremsen
ich habe ihn gezeigt dass wir 100%
erneuerbare Energien brauchen und ich
haben wir ich habe gezeigt dass wir so
unsere Energieversorgung sichern können
ist also alles gut nein die Umstellung
das ist das harte das kostet Geld da
ändern sich Geschäftsmodelle Umstellung
ist immer hart aber es hilft halt nicht
es aufzuschieben weil wenn wir es
aufschieben wird es nur noch Härte also
müssen wir jetzt umstellen und was sie
auch durcheinander bringen den Krieg den
wir haben die Situation die Energiekrise
das hat erstmal nichts mit der
Energiewende zu tun also hören Sie auf
das ist meine Bitte das durcheinander zu
bringen hören Sie auf diese Panik zu
verbreiten weil das was sie antreiben
dafür haben sie ja selber keine Lösung
und unterstützen sie die Energiewende
wenn wir das klug machen und deswegen
braucht es kluge Leute dafür können wir
das schaffen ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
behalten Sie die Hoffnung auch wenn die
Sonne abends untergeht ich kann Ihnen
sagen sie geht auch wieder auf
vielen Dank Herr Kollege bevor
ich der Kollege Uhlich als letzter
Redner das Wort der Teile hat die
afd-fraktion um eine Kurzintervention
gebeten für den Kollegen hillsa Kollege
Hilzingen
jetzt vielen Dank Herr Präsident dass
sie die kurze Dimension zulassen also
die Rede ist trotz der vor Blödsinn zum
Beispiel das
Sonnenstrom nicht schwankt aber ist egal
also es sind paar Sachen dabei gewesen
die sollten sich vielleicht noch mal mit
ihrem Referenten besprechen
oder zu ja wie auch immer meine Frage
ist folgende sie sagten sie wollen sich
unabhängig machen von Diktaturen von
nicht demokratischen Staaten sie wissen
wahrscheinlich dass 95 Prozent der
Solarpaneele für unsere
Photovoltaikanlagen aus China kommen die
Frage ist jetzt ob sie China für einen
durch und durch demokratischen Staat
halten
der Kollege sie können darauf an
[Musik]
da haben sie mal ein Problem gefunden
was tatsächlich eines ist aber wir
wollen ja Probleme lösen und sie nicht
nur beschreiben deswegen sind wir dafür
in Europa
Photovoltaikanlagen zukünftig zu
produzieren wir brauchen die
Windkraftindustrie auch in Deutschland
und interessanter sie sich plötzlich
doch am Begriff Diktatur stören ich
freue mich auf jeden Fall wenn sie damit
helfen das wäre ein schöner Anfang
vielen Dank letzte Rednerin dieser
Debatte ist die Kollegin Katrin Uhlig
bin ist 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der vorliegende
Antrag verkennt leider die aktuelle
Situation on cat-kommissionen sind
sinnvoll und da hat der Kollege hümpfert
eben schon sehr viel zu ausgeführt wenn
wir als Abgeordnete offene Fragen zu
einem komplexen Thema intensiver
diskutieren und mehr Informationen
sammeln möchten um auf dieser Basis dann
für politisches Handeln Empfehlungen zu
bekommen für die Zukunft deshalb räumt
die
Geschäftsordnung wenn nötig auch eine
ganze Legislatur Zeit ein um diese
Informationen zusammenzutragen selbst
wenn wir die Lösungen für unsere
Energieversorgung nicht schon kennen
würden was macht es im Fall der
aktuellen Energieversorgung für einen
Sinn
2024 2025
Handlungsempfehlungen zu haben wohin uns
fossile Energien inklusive Atomkraft
geführt haben sehen wir doch aktuell
jeden Tag Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Importen hohe Energiepreise hoch
Risikotechnologie mit vollgekosten und
endlagerfragen Auswirkungen auf die
Klimakrise das ist kein weiter so mit
alten Techniken geben kann muss in
diesen Zeiten eigentlich auch dem
letzten klar geworden sein nach der
aktuellen Debatte bin ich mir da nicht
so sicher aber da hilft auch keine
oncat-kommission wir wissen auch weil
dies wissenschaftlich erforscht ist
welche massiven Auswirkungen die
Gewinnung von Strom und Wärme aus
fossilen Energieträgern für unser Klima
unsere Umwelt unser was unser Wasser
unsere Luft haben und wir haben gute
Vorstellungen davon welche Auswirkungen
die Klimakrise auf unser Leben haben
wird und wir kennen doch bereits die
Lösung der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien ein Wandel unseres Energie-
weniger von Importen aus anderen Ländern
und senken die Energiepreise
wir haben mit dem osterpaket hier im
Bundestag für einen schnelleren Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien die ersten
wichtigen Weichen bereits gestellt und
arbeiten mit Hochdruck daran den Ausbau
weiter zu beschleunigen wir müssen jetzt
all die Dinge angehen die den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren immer noch blockieren und
ja wir müssen auch unser
strommarktdesign den Gegebenheiten
anpassen weg von zentralen
Großkraftwerken hin zu dezentraler
Energieversorgung aus erneuerbaren
Energien
denn wenn wir die Versorgungssicherheit
langfristig gewährleisten wollen wenn
wir unsere Klima und unsere Gesundheit
schützen wollen wenn wir die Sicherheit
Europas stärken wollen wenn wir uns
unabhängig machen wollen von fossilen
Importen wenn wir den Industriestandort
erhalten und zukunftsfähig Arbeitsplätze
schaffen wollen wenn wir bezahlbare
Energiepreise haben wollen dann brauchen
wir keiner und cat-kommission da müssen
wir einfach die erneuerbaren Energien
schneller ausbauen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Katrin ullig
für Bündnis 90 grün war hier die letzte
Rednerin zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt
die afd-fraktion hat hier diesen Antrag
eingebracht eine onkel-kommission
Sicherstellung der Energieversorgung
einzusetzen darüber wird heute noch
nicht abgestimmt das ganze geht erst mal
in die Ausstellung ja verehrte
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer der
Bundestag hat jetzt einen längeren
abstimmungsmarathon vor sich es wird
dann hier in circa 15 20 Minuten
weitergehen dann übrigens das noch als
kleiner Ausblick mit der Finanzreform
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
auch mit einem Tagesordnungspunkt der
sich mit Russlands Einfluss in Afrika
beschäftigt das alles können Sie
natürlich dann wieder live bei uns
verfolgen wir wollen sie aber in der
Zwischenzeit noch über andere aktuelle
Ereignisse informieren das macht mein
Kollege Florian Bauer in Bonn